president biden is urging action from
the senate on gun reform measures
already passed by the house
democratic senator maisie hirono of
hawaii joins us now she is on the senate
judiciary committee which held hearings
on the issue this week senator good
morning to you thank you for being here
i appreciate you being here on it's an
important morning and what we just laid
out i think is the crux of the issue
politically
for those who support gun reform
republican senators have a base that is
very activist
on the issue and it does not appear you
have the votes given that situation
do you think that president biden should
move forward with executive action to do
what he can
if he can take executive action to
require
universal background checks i say go to
it mr president
but in the meantime one would hope that
we can act on
at least requiring universal background
checks and
closing a three-day background check
loophole
i don't think that is outrageous gun
legislation
we have more gun deaths and violence in
our country than in any others
uh advanced nation uh and these kinds of
mass shootings is uh
it just occurs far too often in our
country
senator the other thing that makes the
united states very unique on the global
stage is the fact that we have in our
constitution this idea of an inherent
right to
access to firearms republican senators
your colleagues there in the senate
are looking to defend that not abridge
it in any way because their voters
believe in that the the repercussions
and side effects notwithstanding
what would you say to those voters
because to move the senators you're
going to have to move them
if they should be listening this morning
what would you say to them
republican senators know that the
constitutional right to own a gun is not
unfettered and the supreme court said so
so sensible gun legislation is something
that does not
go against that constitutional right to
a
firearms and none of us is saying that
that second amendment right should be
taken away
but this is what the republicans are
constantly pushing out the
the fear uh and scaring people that
we are all about taking away guns no we
are for
gun safety laws democratic senator joe
manchin
senator says he does not support the two
house bills that president biden is
pushing um do you do you have you spoken
with him at all do you think he could
his vote could swing on this
i hope that joe would change his mind
because there was a time when he worked
on a bipartisan gun safety bill
and so i certainly hope that that he
will recognize that we need to do
more than what we have done which is
basically nothing
after all these mass shootings that i
hope he recognizes the
the need and there was a time when he
did recognize
the need for gun safety laws
you know your republican colleagues have
pushed back on this what is your message
to them
we have way too much gun violence
and killings in our country yeah and
there
is uh some there are things that we can
do
and why should anyone be against
universal background checks what is the
problem with that
and also closing a three-day loophole so
that
you can't get a gun after three days
of a background check doesn't uh it is
not completed and suddenly you can own a
gun
see that that is hardly what i call
outrageous and the fact is that the
majority
of americans support this kind of
legislation
it's just the republicans who are
totally out of step they must be
enthralled
with the gun lobby and they are doing a
tremendous disservice to
americans in their position more work to
be done yeah more work to be done on
that issue
i want to i want to switch positions
there to a different topic
uh that the issue of diversity the white
house has announced
that it will appoint an asian-american
pacific islander liaison
to increase representation in that
community and voices from that community
you and senator duckworth have removed
your position against
approving straight white nominees
for cabinet positions in the meantime as
a result of that appointment
what more at this point do you think
needs to be done
on the diversity question
the aapi community as well as me and
others i have been advocating with this
administration for more
representation by aapi's in both the
cabinet
as well as in senior level white house
positions so
the naming of this person who i conclude
is someone who will have access
to the to the president to the vice
president to the cabinet who will have
substantive input on issues that impact
our community that is what i'm looking
for and it is a good step
i have had other discussions with a with
the white house and so i have concluded
that
that they are going to do better
and i will work with them to make that
happen senator you're co-sponsoring a
bill that would condemn
anti-asian sentiment among other things
what more needs to be done to stop this
and what exactly does your bill do
and in the past those bills haven't
gotten very far
my bill which is the cobait hate crimes
bill
and grace bay has introduced the
companion bill in the house
it is a totally in my view
non-controversial measure that requires
the attorney general
to appoint a person to review uh these
kinds of
of hate crimes all across the country
and to work with state and local law
enforcement
to make sure that the word gets out
in these communities as to what
constitutes a hate crime
how they can be reported this is a
collection of information so that we can
have
a national approach because this is a
national
issue of these kinds of targeted hate
crimes against
asian americans and pacific islanders
and so
that's what this bill does it is hardly
what i would call controversial however
i have not been able to get
a republican to support it and in fact i
don't hear very many republicans getting
up
and condemning this kind of targeted
attacks against aapis
to the point where the aapis have died
from these attacks and this is why our
community
is so mobilized and concerned we need to
we need to do better we'll keep our eyes
out for a movement on on that bill
you're co-sponsoring
as well as gun reform legislation
senator hirono thank you very much
thank you